Here, I have a bunch of differentsorting algorithms implemented in C++.
We have a quick sort, a bubblesort, a merge sort and an insertion sort.
Let's go ahead and run a benchmark to see whichone's actually fastest.
Here, I'm using the google benchmark library to do the benchmarking.
Here'sthe guts of basically what we're timing here.
Which is that we're going to create a copy of someinitial vector.
And then see how long it takes to sort it.
Which sorting algorithm do you think isgoing to bench to pass this?
Quick sort, Bubble sort, Insertion sort or Merge sort?
Well, here are theresults.
I did include standard sort here just for comparison sake.
But of the four that I mentionedbefore, it looks like insertion sort was the winner.
In this case, insertion sort and bubble sortperformed better than quick sort and merge sort
which is probably the opposite of what a lot ofyou might have expected.
Yes, insertion sort and bubble sort are n-squared algorithms.
Whereas, quicksort is expected nlogn and merge sort is nlogn.
So, why did the n-squared algorithms beat out the nlogn algorithms in this case?
Well, of course, it's because I didn't tell you that the size thatwe're sorting is pretty small, only 16 elements.
But on a fixed small size, like, 16,
Big-Otime complexity of an algorithm is often not the most important factor.
In fact,cache locality and branch predictability often play a much larger role.
Caches and branchprediction don't have as much to do with C++ itself
as they have to do withyour physical processor and memory.
In a real computer, accessing something offof disk is going to be thousands of timesslower
than accessing from RAM which isgoing to be slower than accessing from cache.
Of course, the catch is quantity.
You're going tohave way less RAM than you do have disk space.
And likewise, you have way less cache than you havefor RAM.
On my machine, I have 32 gigabytes of RAM but only 8 megabytes of cache.
Here, I have a structS that has two members x and y which are going to be stored contiguously in memory.
When I call afunction that takes an s, then if I want to access s.x,
the computer will load that memory
wherethis little s is living and put it into cache so it's available.
But it won't just load in s.xalone.
It'll actually grab a whole chunk of memory that's nearby.
So that later, when I very likelywant to access other attributes, like, s.y,
it will already be in the cache.
If you try toaccess memory that was already in the cache, we call that a cache hit.
And if the thing that you'relooking for isn't in the cache, then it's a cache miss.
So, misses are very expensive. Hits are notexpensive.
Here, I have a function for summing up elements of a vector.
I take in the indices thatI want to sum
And then I just loop over them, grabbing that element out of thevector and adding it to the total.
Addition is commutative. So, I'm goingto get the same sum regardless of the order that I add up the indices in.
However,the order matters a lot for cache locality.
If I access element 0 and then 1, 2, 3, 4 and so on,
that's really easy for the processor to predict.
But if the indices were a random permutationof all the possible valid indices of the vector,
then the processor is going to have no way topredict what memory to load next. It's just random.
And here's the results.
The blue line shows the inorder access of the vector.
So, just going index 0, 1, 2 and so on.
Whereas, the red line is for accessingthings in a random order and adding them up.
The x-axis here is how many bytes long the vectoris.
So, approximately four times the length of the vector because the elements are integers.
I chose to use bytes for the units instead of length
Because, from this picture you canpractically read off how big my caches are.
The biggest kink in this graph is right here around8 megabytes.
And I have 8 megabytes of L3 cache.
That means, to the left, the computer couldpotentially put the entire vector into cache.
Now that doesn't actually happen because itwouldn't really know to do that ahead of time.
And there's other things using memory on mycomputer, of course.
But to the right of the line, the entire vector won't fit into cache.
So,if the computer isn't able to predict what memory you're going to access next ahead of time,
thenyou're going to pay that penalty of cash misses.
On the other hand, for the in order access pattern,
it didn't seem to make any difference at all whenwe crossed the 8 megabyte cash threshold.
That's because this access pattern is so predictable the computer can just put the datathat you need into cache before you ever need it.
Okay, accessing a vector's elements in a randomorder is a pretty uncommon and silly thing to do.
How about a more realistic example?
Matrixmultiplication
Here's a straightforward way to implement matrix multiplication.
I takea and b which represent N by N matrices.
So, they're both vectors that contain N times Nelements.
The purpose of the function is to put the matrix product of a and b into the output vector.
We start by initializing the output to all zeros.
Then we just do a simple doublefor-loop over the rows and columns.
If you remember the ijth entry of the outputmatrix should be the sum over k of a_ik times b_kj
This third for-loop is to implement the sum.
As we loop over k, i and j are fixed. So, this term isn't changing at all.
This next termwe are changing.
But it's just moving with k, one element at a time.
The problem is with thisthird term.
Here, when k increases by 1 because we have N times k, we're now jumping N elements ahead.
So, this is bad for cache locality.
Here I have the exact same function,
except the only difference isthat instead of looping i, j, k, I'm looping i, k, j.
Now let's take a look at the inner loopnow that it's a loop over j instead of k.
As j changes, this element is moving one elementat a time in order. That's fine.
i and k are fixed. So, this isn't changing at all. That's also fine.
And now the third term is also okay.
Again as j changes, this is just moving one element at a time.
So, all three terms are good for cache locality.
So, I went ahead and wrote a variation forall six orders of i, j and k.
Let's compare the performance.
And here, we have it a hugedifference in performance just based off of the loop order.
As we reasoned before, loopswhere the inner loop was j.
So, i, k, j and k, i, j, those performed way better than the others.
So, inthis case, having good cache locality gave us over a 2x performance improvement.
That's prettygood.
These times were for 64 by 64 matrices.
And when the matrices are that small,
cachelocality is pretty much the dominating feature.
However, this is not the end of the line forbigger matrices.
If you're working with bigger matrices, of course, doing block matrix algorithmsacross multiple threads is going to be faster.
However, for smaller matrices, you can probablycompute the entire answer in less time that it would take to spawn a single thread.
The nextfactor that you should really consider when thinking about the performance of your code isbranch predictability.
A branch is just something that affects the control flow of your code,
like,an if-statement or a for-loop or a while-loop.
Whether or not the if statement turns out trueor false determines what the next instruction forthe program is going to be.
Modern processors arereally amazing in what they can do.
Gone are the days where your program is executed line by line.
Amodern processor will happily execute things in a different order than you asked for.
And potentially,even executing multiple things at the same time.
If you want to add say 3 to some variable x andthen 5 to another variable y,
there's no reason the processor should wait in order for the storeto x to be finished before starting the store toy.
They can execute at the same time.
There are manymany situations like this that your processor will try to take advantage of.
As long as you couldn'tpossibly tell the difference that anything funny was going on,
your processor is free to do themout of order or in parallel.
But what happens when you get to a branch point?
Your processorcan't know which instruction to execute next until it's fully evaluated the condition.
In situations like this, your processor may just guess.
If the last 10 loops your processorfound that x was bigger than threshold and this one was executed,
then on the 11th time, itmight just start executing this ahead of time.
As long as it predicted correctly, it getsa big head start on the next computation.
We say that a branch is predictable or hasgood branch predictability
if the processor is able to correctly predict
which of theoutcomes is going to occur a lot of the time.
For this function get_product, I'm doing somethingkind of artificial.
But it will allow us to really see how good the branch predictor is.
I start witha product of 1.0 and then I loop through all the elements.
For each element that's bigger thansome threshold, I multiply by 2 times the element.
And if it's not bigger than the threshold,then I multiply by 1.5 times the element.
In this case, the predictability of the branchdepends a lot on
what percentage of elementsin the vector are bigger than the threshold.
If90% of things are bigger than the threshold,
then the branch predictor could justpredict true and be right 90% of the time.
If only 10% of things were biggerthan the threshold,
the branch predictor could just predict false all the time and still be right90% of the time.
But if half are bigger and half are smaller, then the branch predictor can't do anybetter than 50%.
And here's the graph that proves it.
Here, I used a uniform random numbergenerator to generate numbers between 0 and 1.
and then set a threshold between 0 and 1.
Inboth cases, when the threshold was either very low or very high, the branch became predictable.
And wegot a nearly 2x performance improvement from the branch predictor.
Of course, the worst performanceis dead center at 50% when the branch predictor can do little more than flip a coin.
I do want to warnyou, though.
Compilers are really really good.
So, if you try to do this benchmark yourself,
dependingon the compiler and optimization settings and the time of day or whatever,
you might get differentresults.
There's a good chance that if you try this with your compiler,
you might see a completely flatline.
And if that's the case,
what probably happened is that your compiler completely optimized thebranch away.
There's a good chance your compiler would optimize it to something like this
thatdoesn't involve any branching.
And if that's the case, you would just see a flat line.
Well, that'sall I've got. Thanks for watching.
If you liked the video, don't forget to like comment and subscribe.
Thanks to my patrons and donors for supporting me.